[Music]
good morning Mr Scott I trust your
journey wasn't too
unpleasant first class the manager of
the hotel has requested the pleasure of
your
company welcome to the Continental I'm a
sensation this Grand institution is part
of a very old and sacred fabric Wiston
what am I doing here your brother stole
something from me I don't know what
Frankie
is what Frankie
took is very important to a lot of very
dangerous people if you don't retreat
I'll bring the weight of this whole
institution down on you
both this isn't the kind of thing that
we just walk away
[Music]
from we kill cornac taking his damn
house and everything that comes with it
a takeover of the whole hotel how are we
supposed to believe a guy in an asscar
can pull this off it's a
creat it's time to Outsource perhaps
some of our guests are
[Music]
available chirome so you're here for
Revenge oh no this is about Justice Red
Light
active and the way we
[Music]
go you thought you could outsmart the
high table how foolish of
[Music]
you can you dig
it this is my house get all in
second what I'm asking you to do is not
easy I'm offering you a chance to decide
who you want to
be looking for the man in the nascot I'm
sorry
I